hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be my game of thrones teaser QA I
think this is actually my first QA of
the year just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far this is going to be all about
season 6 stuff so here we go first
question David asks I thought that a
person had to die in the house of the
many-faced God for it to be used by the
Faceless Men well I'll actually just
take like a version of your question yes
you do have to die before they can use
your face because it takes a physical
face that they have to put on just to be
clear the technique that the Faceless
Men used to wear other people's faces to
look like other people involves a
combination of practical effects like an
actual mask and there's a supernatural
aspect to it to that we haven't learned
about they just teased that at the end
of last year so the show tends to handle
really deep mythology like that really
mystical things in roundabout ways so
don't expect a complete literal
explanation of how faces worn that being
said just because we see faces of people
that are alive here doesn't mean they're
gonna die this season it just means that
they can die all men must die the funny
thing about that is the line that
donairs had a couple seasons ago where
she's like we're not men that doesn't
mean she's safe but it would be a giant
middle finger if she were to rally all
these people her cause in the east kuro
a couple dragons and then just die off
it just went nowhere next question yeah
Mallette asks is the face next to John
Stannis or manse it's actually Stannis
but I don't think there's any
significance to faces appearing next to
each other beyond family houses or
storylines so like Stannis is on one
side of John here this is Egret on the
other side I saw a couple people
wondering if this is ollie no this is
Egret some of these faces just appear
next to characters that they died near
or characters from their same house like
you have Joffrey's face Tywin's faces
next to him but I don't think there's
any significance to faces appearing next
to other faces like like all these faces
in this big spread here doesn't mean
that they're all going to come together
and die I do think by the end of the
series though that the characters who
have survived will converge you have all
these main characters over in the East
you have all these characters in
Westeros you have all these characters
in the north if there's going to be an
actual battle in the war for the dawn
then the people who are left are going
to have to rally together at a certain
point that's way way far away in the
distance next question Joe swamps and
asks do you think that Sansa is pregnant
with Ramsay's baby and what he
think she'll do about it abortion which
was one performed by liza and after you
got impregnated by little finger which
made her go nuts adoption by another
nipple house such as the umbers so he
actually had some good examples here
babies raised by the people you know
like mysterious evil babies no i don't
think that stance is pregnant the
biggest reasons i think people came up
with this idea is because of her bulky
winter coat and because it's probably
the worst thing that could happen to her
after she escapes from ramsey just based
on the evidence they present us with it
doesn't seem like her being that
pregnant pregnant enough to show would
be a thing you have to remember that the
new season will pick up in the moments
after season five ended in ramsey didn't
consummate their marriage that long ago
and if Santa's gonna have this big
revenge story line like they've been
teasing she can't be like super prego
riding around on a horse it would
completely derail that storyline now
given all that there is no proof that
she is not pregnant so if you want to
believe that she's pregnant you're not
completely in the wrong but what is one
of the good things you can do with
babies born of noble blood Sansa doesn't
necessarily have royal blood in the
sense that Melisandre is looking at Jon
Snow saying there is power in your blood
like an actual King Stannis is blood for
instance the closest Sansa comes to
royalty are the kings of winter the
ancient start Kings before everyone bent
the need akon the Conqueror so there
were to be a baby and Sansa is going to
stay in the north her story lines going
to keep her up there I would love the
sea Melisandre use that to invoke a
blessing from the red God so traditional
abortion or abortion by fire take your
pick but I don't think the shows going
to do that of the list of WTF things
that you can do on a TV show I feel like
HBO would draw the line at throwing a
baby into a fire like okay we're going
to take a hard pass on that next
question catharsis s maybe REO will put
on the mask of her father and run around
slang people as Ned Stark the only
problem with that is that usually when
you change faces it's implied that you
have to be someone of approximate size
so Aria wouldn't change her face and
suddenly being six feet tall you have to
remember that is it adorable as Maisie
Williams is she's the size of a hobbit
so it's not like she's gonna double in
size by wearing another mask but yes I
do think she's kind of come back to
Westeros and she's going to find a way
to check those names off of her list i
think the lesson last year when she took
down Meryn Trant is the
she's always going to be that Arya Stark
person no matter what else she tries to
do that's always going to be inside of
her if anything the faceless men would
find a way to take Joffrey's face and
she would wear Joffrey's face and kill
sir see that would be amazing that'd be
way better than her wearing Ned Stark's
face next question Rami asks so now does
this teaser confirm that there's no
chance of seeing jon snow alive well
okay so I think people are confused
about what's going on with Jon Snow the
most commonly held belief is that he's
going to be resurrected by Melisandre in
order to be resurrected you have to die
first so when we're seeing him here it
really doesn't mean anything because
they're just messing with us but on the
show he will have to die that's why HBO
keeps saying that he is dead they
haven't been lying to people you have to
read between the lines they've just been
leaving off the rest of that sentence
he's definitely dead and he's coming
back they just been omitting things in
the name of WTF reveals there are a
number of ways that John can come back
but logically it seems that Melisandre
will resurrect him in the way thoreau
sameer resurrected beric Dondarrion so
if you have a friend who isn't super
familiar with the books and he's like
wait you know is Jon Snow still alive
you can tell them no he's definitely
dead but he's totally coming back in a
big WTF way if you haven't read the
books I don't think it's been totally
clear when people talk about jon snow
coming back it's it's been a long-held
belief since they published book five
like oh yeah he's definitely coming back
there is no book that says that he comes
back so when people say oh he's
definitely coming back because of these
pieces of evidence technically it's not
a spoiler it's just a theory that people
have had the last five years to work out
remember book five was published I think
back in 2011 right around when the show
was getting started next question selca
asks maybe a bite of Lady Stoneheart I
actually I don't think the show is going
to do that because I think it would take
away some of the WTF from this Jon Snow
reveal in the sansa plotline in the
books the Lady Stoneheart stuff happens
before the Jon Snow stuff happens so I
think that's one of the reasons why the
show has put it off is in they wanted
this big jon snow come back to be like
the biggest WTF ever and if they were to
do Lady Stoneheart it would completely
undercut that like oh we've already seen
a character that we love come back so
jon snow coming back not that special
and as for Sansa storyline she's on this
hero's journey where she starts out as a
sweet summer child
oh sweet summer child you don't know
anything a winter endures all these
hardships and finds a way to survive
toughens up until finally she starts
fighting back the Lady Stoneheart plot
is an extreme version of that like I'm
not going to take anymore I'm going
to wreck everyone that I run into so
they were to do Lady Stoneheart it would
also make Sansa's storyline less special
next question Billy asks imagine if John
said the long night is coming in the
Dead come with it and walks in on
Alliser thorne and the other Nights
Watch members and they're all like WTF
and then he just wrecks them well the
bad ones I do think you know when jon
snow comes back everyone is going to
poop their pants let's assume for the
purpose of this video that he is coming
back the problem with him killing a
bunch of people there were a bunch of
Nights Watch brothers that killed him
there but they are already really under
man so I think he's going to need every
single person that he can get to fight
the army of the Dead that he says is
coming in the name of Awesome TV they
might throw a red shirt under the bus
for Jon Snow to kill but I don't think
he's gonna walk around killing every
single person that stabbed him that
night next question more Jon Snow Jesse
asks Johnson said on the show season 5
episode 6 the winter's coming and the
Dead come with it but they changed it in
the teaser he said the long night is
coming in the Dead come with it very
obvious that he's coming back I think
the teaser is really just messing with
us in the way that they changed that
line I don't think that's more evidence
that he's coming back but I definitely
think that they're winking at us from
behind the camera I'm not expecting that
long night quote from John Snow to be an
actual thing on the show I'm not
expecting that to be an actual line of
dialogue I think it'd be more likely
that the three-eyed Raven or Melisandre
would quote something about the long
night old man did have a tale about it
so people are aware that it exists it
exists in legend I will be really
surprised if we get a vision that Jon
Snow has when he exists in the state
between life and death like when
Melisandre brings him back if we see Jon
Snow POV during that I'd be really
surprised next ? each asks I never
realized that Max von Sydow played a
part in Game of Thrones yes he's
actually a recast version of the
three-eyed Raven there was a different
actor at the end of season 4 there's a
number of reasons why they could have
recast the character he's going to have
a lot of speaking lines they'll be
walking around via visions it seems like
so maybe they wanted a stronger actor or
the
after that used to play the three-eyed
Raven was unavailable they've recast the
mountain a couple times but I'm a big
fan of Max von Sydow so I'm totally fine
with the recast next question the wizard
asks do you think there'd be an army of
the risen dead that's not fighting for
the night's king but for the other side
maybe Melisandre will raise one no I
think they want to position this is the
army of the Living vs the army of the
Dead day versus night it wouldn't be
quite as special if everybody had
zombies to fight for them that being
said if Melisandre were to raise jon
snow from the dead it's not quite the
same thing is White Walkers raising
White's as in animating corpses so you
could say Melisandre is raising an army
by proxy because she's raising Jon Snow
he will probably be involved with
leadership of any force that faces the
White Walkers and their army but really
I think the largest number of soldiers
it is going to be fighting for the sight
of light would come from Daenerys just
because of the sheer quantity of
followers she's accumulating now the
Dothraki storyline is really going to
spell that out I think she has to win
them over even though it seems like they
absolutely hate her guts right now so
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions he's always a ton of fun to do
I'm happy to start doing him again
hopefully they'll be more time in the
future is this show start moving around
and I know a lot of you are wondering
about the next trail like the first big
trailer they haven't announced a
specific date but I know you know you
would have expected to see it by now
actual footage but remember the season
was pushed back by a couple weeks so I
think they just delayed the release of
actual footage by a couple weeks too so
I'd expect to see more material more
photos more actual footage from season
six in the next two to three weeks but
no official date yet and congratulations
to this week's giveaway winners remember
it's a double giveaway because it's just
awesome that they finally started
releasing teasers arianne Williams and
the beary bear you guys went $20 amazon
gift cards be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so and get
your contact info i'm probably going to
do another bonus video about the long
night just because it's such an
interesting point in history but if
there are any specific bonus videos you
guys want please leave your requests in
the comments in case you guys haven't
seen it there was a big star wars
episode 8 teaser yesterday i'm so
surprised that they started releasing
stuff from that you can click here to
learn all about what's going on with
that and you can click here to watch
that game of thrones teaser again thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you